I have for the first time a fidget
spinner here everyone is going crazy
about these so I'm really excited to
give it a spin that's it
this is what people are going crazy
about can we take it a step further I
got all the coolest fidget spinner trace
if you have one spinning watch this you
can put another one on time what can I
say
I spun since the day I was born I know
what you're thinking there's no way you
can make anything cooler than this Felix
oh wait there is do you know how much
[ __ ] you gonna get with these boy if
you're wearing these you get insulated
in sabitch it's the lunchbox you see
someone you don't like just give them
this
you thought fidget spinners weren't cool
well now they are back cool again that's
definitely cool I know what you're
thinking there's nothing cooler than
this guess again what if you put a
fidget spinner on a fidget spinner
it's fully charged I'm glad we bought 15
for this what if you put a fidget on
your fidget something might happen when
we do this we have never done this trip
for I can guarantee you no one you might
live with it
I'm yes
now that's fidget spin you thought feed
your spinners we're gay well have you
had them on your nipples yet Felix get
up you don't wait you lazy bastard shut
up you gonna shoot video what'd I say
I'm doing a power nap today I am going
to become what I love the fidget
spinning we have this idea and we can
use this chair
it's PDS chair but [ __ ] them we're gonna
modify this chair
for me to become the greatest fidget
spinner alive all right it's done okay
so the idea is that I think it's pretty
obvious what they don't teach you this
is school all right so I'm gonna need
some help with the tape
wait wait wait for the detail my haters
doubted me said I could never become a
fidget [ __ ] you [ __ ] look
but will it spin we're just gonna have
to take it to the streets to find out
also my hand is stuck if you could help
me please
thank you let's go this is the first
time I see myself I'm goddamn beautiful
finally I've transformed be able to get
everything
[Music]
I feel so sick the sickness is an issue
but it's not a problem I was born like
this my chromosomes
oh yeah baby
[Music]
here we go here we go yeah
it's I'm the coldest man alive why does
no one care it's almost like I don't
exist we must be spending too fast like
they can't see us
I will slow down my speeds
please give me a good spin boys
oh no I'm doing the other way hurry
please
where are you going now can I get a spin
please just one spin spin me swing
please spin me
mama-mama yeah
yeah
to tell
please spend me don't go I love you
please spend me yes yes oh yeah now
don't push me out in traffic yeah thank
you can you spin
ah thank you thank you very much
I was great thank you very much I need
someone that can spin me like a real
spinner like a real fidget spinning
probe
come on right
oh my god thank you
never done it with a man before hell
yeah
such power
I'm ready to take this off now and take
a little nap being fidget spinner isn't
as easy as it seems leave a like